we begin this hour with a look at police
reform in america a public call for
change reaching its strongest level in
decades
a funeral will be held for rashad brooks
today in atlanta
his death at the hands of police nearly
two weeks ago
gave that reform effort new urgency
protests against police brutality began
in minneapolis after
george floyd was killed there on
memorial day demonstrations quickly
spread to all 50 states and around the
world
nearly one month later the city where it
started is still working to make change
happen
police unions as you know have a lot of
influence in the way policing is done in
this country and critics say
the police officers federation of
minneapolis has resisted changes in the
past
in an interview you'll see first right
here on cbs this morning
we spoke with the union's president
that's minneapolis police lieutenant bob
kroll is his name we also talked to
other leaders of the union
you're looking at rich walker senior
cheryl schmidt and anna hedberg
we asked cole why he told his members in
a private letter earlier
quote what is not being told is the
violent criminal history of george floyd
we also asked the union leaders if they
see a larger problem with policing
bob cole do you think there is a
systemic racism problem in the
minneapolis police force
i do not racial issues
certainly need to be addressed and we
are willing to work through that as we
have done in in year
after year many years in the police
department we are all engaged
there are racial issues is it systemic
racism not in my opinion
a lot of people are throwing systemic
racism in our police department
i can tell you as an african-american
male i personally
do not believe this exists our city
council is very diverse
we got a black attorney general we have
a black police chief
i am the first african-american ever
elected to the minneapolis
police federation in 152 years you know
what i see
i see progress we're progressing forward
i think it's very hard the only people i
hear saying there's no such thing as
systemic racism in the police department
are police
i don't know how you move forward unless
there's some acknowledgement about what
people believe
we can definitely acknowledge that
people think and perceive that there's
systemic racism because that
that is all that is being said about law
enforcement today
i mean it's really difficult to come up
with the the answer to seeing something
so
horrific do any of you think there need
to be reforms in the police department
certainly absolutely what would you
change yes and we want to be a part of
that
i think we would be better served by
listening to what the community wants to
see changed
and then work with them to implement
that i think the first thing that we got
need to do is sit down with community
leaders and listen
you brought up george floyd's past
history
what was the purpose in bringing up his
past history
well i i did not bring that out in
public
and and you need to understand the
context
our officers had been literally under
fire they had been shot at
five times in the in the five following
days um
post his death and it wasn't any intent
of mine to
question his history the context of that
was a
scribbling of what we as a board had
been working on and doing
and a morale builder because our
department had completely
suffered a devastating hit to their
morale
particularly when the third precinct was
given away and i
sent an email to the membership period
and that was not intended to go any
further but see bob that's the thing
you're calling it a morale builder the
city's on fire because they feel this
man has been murdered by a police
officer
what is the purpose in bringing that up
i didn't even bring the criminal history
up
so you're saying it was a private it was
a private one small segment of a very
lengthy letter and it doesn't say
anything about what's contained in
criminal history under what
circumstances bob do you think a police
officer should lose
his or her job should lose should be
fired
that's just a wide i'm sorry but that's
just a wide open end of hypotheticals
that
i couldn't begin to answer i'm sorry is
it so wide
we could sit for the rest of the week
and play out scenarios where they could
loot where they could and should lose
their job
there's a false narrative out there also
that we appeal and fight all discipline
and win it and that's simply not true